so heute eigentlich bin ich viel zu müde zum stream sondern aber ich habe
mir gedacht war gestern hat und da war heute wenigstens mal kurz an
ich habe auch was vergessen im letzten video ich habe nicht einmal gesagt zu
den leuten die sollen sich gefällig eine linux vm installieren wenn sie sicher ins
internet wollen das wäre in dem video ein schon wieder ganz praktisch gewesen
es zu erwähnen aber habe ich vergessen ist mittlerweile so standart bei mir
schon ich denke da gerne mehr dran
oh moment teams hat mein sound wieder verstellt ah teams ist so scheiße
team sagt einfach so extrem übrigens mein router wurde angeblich verschickt
wobei jetzt eigentlich das switch den ich letztens im stream gezeigt habe ist
on the way mal gucken ob das ding wirklich taugt da
mache ich ein video zu weil ich finde es ist preisleistungsmäßig echt richtig
geiles ding für daheim 85 euro 2 10 g ports 8 1 g ports ist massif nice
ab in die vm hätte ideen ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht aber da müsste ich
mein mikrofon und so auch irgendwie zur vm durch leiten leiten was wäre eine
gute alternative zu teams naja was ist sonst noch so verbreitet aktuell slack
als chat hat slack mittlerweile voice ist gar nicht zoom was auch immer die teams
ist schon ok nur das ist nur dieses rum stellen
diese auch ich habe den preis schon mal auch gar nicht angeguckt geht da noch
funktioniert nur dieses rum stellen an der mikrofon lautstärke geht mir
wirklich extrem auf den sack pack weight warum krieg weight
ich weiß ich weil bei cac weight einfach
discord hey discord würde ich sofort auf der
arbeit verwenden aber discord ist nicht business genug für die krassen
business stonks leute bei uns die verstehen den sinn von discord nicht ich
mein mit datenschutz kann da keiner kommen weil teams und microsoft ist mein
der einzige grunde diese haben könnten wäre ja aber wir haben den vertrag mit
microsoft und kein mit discord ist halt die logik man macht im stonks business
umfeld halt gerne verträge über sachen die nicht sein dürfen damit man sagen
kann man hatte einen vertrag gemacht dass es nicht sein darf wenn es trotzdem
passiert ist ja
doch ich finde teams ja muss ich aus ich bin teams gar nicht so schlecht
normale telephone calls gehen mit discord aber nicht wirklich
nee aber mit unserem teams auch nicht richtig
habe ich übrigens auch noch eine des clamp offen ich weiß nicht
schaue live aus dem rein zu exzellent aus dem rein ist nicht bisschen kalt
gerade
jetzt IQ wieder big brain ja leute ich wir müssen demnächst mal ihr wisst ja
dass ich für für heim automatisierung den kram hier verwende und die haben
jetzt eine neue version rausgauen die hat übrigens auch massig
sicherheitsprobleme das zur zeit aber es hat mich nicht betroffen
die eine neue version und ich kann meine ich kann meinen kram nicht
verabdeiten die haben jetzt irgendwas gemacht dass
ich meine installation nicht verabdeiten kann und zwar steht jetzt immer da ich
habe ein unsupportes was steht da unsupportes system was irgendwie nicht
gesund ist oder sowas ich weiß nicht warum das ging die ganze zeit aber ich
habe irgendwas installiert was sie nicht mögen
deswegen werde ich das mal in der vm verfrachten und neu installieren das
kann man teilweise im stream machen aber man sieht das produkt immer noch
ziemlich nice aber ich weiß nicht warum die sowas machen ja der steht da ist
es nicht gesund meine installation ist nicht gesund steht da weiß nicht warum
ich habe einen sub übersehen oder das gem train ist am start ja das
stripes oder sieben neunzehn monate alter
massive subscriptions welchen router hast du dir geholt wie gesagt jetzt nicht
router switch den da der ist nämlich optimal für mein schreibtisch auf einem
schreibt sich habe ich aktuellen billigen 5 port tp link stehen und da
kriege ich 8 1g und 2 10g
was ja nice ist da kann ich nämlich den 10g port mit meinem 10g switch
verbinden hinten im ich sag mal im rechenzentrum im serverraum den zweiten
anschluss mache ich aber ein rechner weil das der einzige ist der 10g
uplink brauche und dann habe ich immer noch eine 10g verbindung zwischen den
switches und kann die 1g ordentlich verwenden
aber nicht dass ich das jemals auslasten würde aber ich könnte dann von mehreren
gleichzeitig gigabit speed machen
ich habe slack nicht empfohlen ich habe gesagt was es sonst noch so gibt
overlay drei monaten für den sub
jan er 34 prime subscription dankeschön messen subscription hier iq plus plus für
den chat hier gleich platzter kopf
über docker nachgedacht im bezug auf was ich habe das aktuell im docker laufen
das problem ist nur dass die dies das setup nicht mehr unterstützen ich habe
ein ubuntu 1804 auf dem server habe ich mal abgekradet heute nebenbei auf 204
und der mag das nicht weil das nicht homosystem style genug ist keine ahnung
habe ich auch kein bock drauf mich danach zu richten ich mache es einfach in
der vm und gut ist vm und fertig ja wenn ich daheim train nerv denn ist dann
musst du ffz installieren kannst du so sachen ausblenden hier so was nicht
das da das da da kannst du so ein kram ausblenden guck dann hast du nämlich
zig milliarden optionen für den chat wenn du das installiert hast dann kannst
dann zum beispiel auch so was sagen wie halb halb und irgendwo kann man glaube
ich den halb train ausblenden lassen guck bärm da ist er weg der halb train hat
sich ausgescampt und es kommt dann nicht wieder guck mal ich kann nicht wieder
einblenden mach mal ich refresche mal da ist er wieder
hui aber glück gehabt
wie habe ich den zelt wie gesagt ich habe auf eigenem server in eigenem docker
installiert mit diesem mit diesem in stoller skript ich weiß dass das
deprecated ist aber es ist schon hart zwischen wir supporten das nicht mehr
und der installer geht einfach nicht ich meine ist ja schön wenn jetzt also ich
ja ich verstehe dass ich es auf eigene gefahr mache aber man sollte zumindest
erlaubnis zu updaten
meine aktivität scale diagonal ja wir sind schon über horizontal und
vertikale skalieren raus
da konnte ich heute den lacher bringen auf der arbeit in einem meeting die
haben auch irgendwas erzählt dass das agil ist und es ging das überlegen es
ging glaube ich um irgendwelche confluence plugins die aus verschiedenen
quellen irgendwie sich daten zünden können oder so was da habe ich gefragt
ob das auch horizontal ob das auch diagonal skaliert das fanden sie
irgendwie lustig ich habe das eigentlich eher eher gesagt um sie ein bisschen zu
verarschen aber die haben sich verstanden ich glaube die fanden das
einfach lustig also sie haben es verstanden die haben aber gedacht ich
mache ich mache voll den geilen ich war voll den geilen stonks businesswitz
weil wollte ich das eigentlich eher wollte ich ein bisschen veräppeln aber
ok
wie funktioniert bei dir das noch mal mit der next cloud zu hause dass du
sicher unterwegs drauf zu gar nicht ich greife nicht von unterwegs drauf zu
mal nicht mehr erstens sagt next cloud einfach nur ich mag das überhaupt nicht
ich habe es nur noch weil ich die ganze zeit hatte ich will das unbedingt
ablösen durch einfach nur in den kall darf und uns hüngstigen oder was auch
immer next aus geht mir so auf den keks ich mag mag es überhaupt nicht ja ich
meine jeder jeder der es gerne benutzt ist ok kann er machen
sache nix dagegen aber ich mag es nicht ja und sie fallen ich nehm sing sing und
gut ist das gibt es überall und ich muss mal gucken so und aber ich kann
dir sagen ich kann dir sagen dass an sich ist eine gute frage ich kann dir
sagen was du machen musst also eine sache würde ich auch definitiv nicht
machen das steht zwar in vielen jahre sudo ist alles schon gefixt bei uns auf
der arbeit bei mir privat überall also eine sache solltest du definitiv nicht
machen auch wenn das in guides drinne steht und das ist deine next cloud
direkt ans internet hängen also indem du genau wie das hier ist magst
gerade in dem du port weiterleitest das würde ich auf gar keinen fall machen du
brauchst auf jeden fall ein ein reverse proxy davor
ich würde nie anders ich würde next cloud nie im leben ans internet hängen
genauso wie ich mein home assistant nie ins internet hängen würde was man jetzt
ja auch wieder gesehen hat dass dienen die hatten riesigen sicherheits lücke
dass jemand konnte quasi alles abfragen ohne sich einzuloggen
das passiert mit dem reverse proxy davor nicht so oft weil der unterschied
zwischen home assistant oder next cloud oder was auch immer hängt direkt im
internet
und es hängt über reverse proxy im internet ist dass der reverse proxy
dazwischen steht also sprich wenn du beispielsweise reverse proxy mit basic
ausmacht dann musst du erst mal dich dort anmelden dass du weiter geleitet
wirst auf den eigentlichen dienst das nächste stellenanzeigen video ich habe
mir schon einiges raus ich ich weiß nicht ob ich das dieses wochenende macht
aber es dauert auf jeden fall nicht mal lang so und also wenn du wenn du da
kam ins internet irgendwie stellst dann würde ich auf jeden fall also wenn du
direkt ins internet stellen willst damit auf jeden fall nur mit reverse proxy
davor machen und auch mit gültigem zertifikat ordentlichen passwort was
aber noch viel besser ist wenn so kann man das machen das ist vom setup her
auch easy der der einfachste reverse proxy ist eindeutig der hier das sind
zwei zeilen in der konfig mit kali dann hast du reverse proxy am start
ja kannst du entweder so oft kommando zeile starten oder du schreibst die
zwei sachen rein und und gut ist sondern muss noch basic ausgeben aber was
viel sicherer ist oder viel besser meiner meinung nach ist wenn du vpn
nimmst so und da musst du dir überlegen wie ich das mache so hatte ich das so
hatte ich das ursprünglich auch mal aber wie gesagt schon ist schon eine ganze
weile her ich kauf greife auf mein zeug nicht mehr nicht mehr von außen zu ich
sind mir ab und zu ein paar sachen aufs handy aber ich brauche keinen permanenten
zugriff von außen da drauf ist nicht so nicht so wild aber eine vpn ist auf
jeden fall die bessere variante da muss der ersten vpn aufs handy machen dich
einwählen und danach nextcloud aufmachen oder oder home assistant oder was auch
immer wer ist am besten wire gart es ist am einfachsten einzurichten
entweder kann ein router schon direkt irgendwas vpn mäßiges oder du nimmst
dir wenn du gar nichts hast was schon läuft nimmst den raspberry pi
machst wir ja gar drauf wenn du dann auf nummer sicher gehen willst machst du
machst du eine dmz an einem router dass du quasi die port weiterleitet von außen
auf den vpn server da machst du eine einwahl und nur von da nachdem du dich
quasi identifiziert hast vpn angemeldet hast darfst du dann rüber also das ist
die die sicherste variante genau aber das mit reverse proxy kann man auch
machen aber ich bin mittlerweile ich stelle
den kram gar nicht mehr ins internet ich habe ich habe nur amazon reflink
drinnen ja gut was soll ich da machen kannst du mal was zu ipsec sagen ja es
ist ipsec und es ist alt und es wird aber von apple standardmäßig unterstützt
aber es ist ok aber die konfig ist scheiße unter linux also die ipsec
konfig ist wirklich massive pains champ wenn du die von hand machen willst
ne nicht so der hier ja ja du kannst auch ipsec ipsec mit ipv6 machen klar das
ist glaube ich sogar im ipv6 standard irgendwie mit drin ipsec glaub
das sogar ich glaube noch cooler als mit ipv4 habe ich aber echt noch nicht
gemacht da ist wenn es dir gefällt ist pock du hast
sogar den weg auf twitter gefunden auf was label ich bin scheiß auf twitch
gefunden
price champ punkt orc nicht punkt kommen punkt orc gesinkt was anderes
wie gesagt ich weiß nicht ob das das woche noch klappt aber es dauert nicht
mehr lang richtig
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht warum ich die andere begrüßung genommen
haben kann ich jetzt an der stelle auch mal sagen also es gab ja schon die die
wildesten vermutungen in den kommentaren warum ich nicht mal hallo jungs und
medel sagt es gab es gab auch leute die haben vermutet dass es aus diversity
gründen und kann oder wurde sich irgendwelche sachen wieder zusammen
gedichtet warum ich nicht mehr warum ich jetzt hallo leute ich mal hallo hallo
jungs und medel sagt ich kann es dir gar nicht so genau sagen also daran liegt
es zumindest nicht also zumindest nicht als hätte ich mir jetzt aktiv gedanken
drüber gemacht hat mir gedacht ich will niemand ausgrenzen und sonst was also
wenn sich davon jemand ausgegrenzt fühlt da kann ich ihm auch nicht helfen wenn
ich hallo jungs und medel sagt aber warum ich nicht mehr sage ist ich habe ja
jetzt quasi mehr oder weniger so ein bisschen für mich ja auch neu mit
youtube wieder angefangen und ich habe gedacht ich mache einfach mal ich habe
ein video eigentlich nur gemacht so spontan so habe ich dann die leute was
geht hier ist der max oder irgendwie sowas und habe ich mir gedacht wisst ihr
was irgendwie mag ich dass dass das so was neues ist ja also was aus meinem
klo geworden ist mein klo ist so krass
mein klo ist so krass dass es von russischen channel das video geklaut wurde
hier beat beat death 24 hat mein video geklaut von meinem klo
binst wo ist es
wo ist es leute so viele close ich blick ihn immer durch
ja der typ hat mein video geklaut und der chat hat schon gesagt ich soll ihn
striken aber ist mir eigentlich egal hier da ist mein video guck mal
hallo jungs und medels hier ist der max und ihr habt mich jetzt tatsächlich so weit dass
ich beat death 24 ohne scheiß ein video von meinem klo mache ich meine ihr wisst ja
das ist kein normales klo das ist ein special klo mit aber das geht immer noch außer dass es
zwischenzeitlich theoretisch hätte brennen können
ja der typ hat einfach mal ein klo video geklaut ich kann es ja auch nicht ändern
kennst du ein terminal was um punto von liggen das muss mit klo um terminal
funktionieren wenn dann von konfig richtig eingestellt ist eigentlich
würde mich wundern wenn ich wenn es kann sogar emojis anzeigen mittlerweile kommt
auf den vorkomm bestimmt auf die font konfig an guckt euch mal die comments an
der macht millionen mit der werbung ja krass krass krass krass millionen macht
er alle der kann sich wahrscheinlich vor geld kaum noch retten weil das video
geklaut hat aber zu der frage mit dem klo und dem klo geht es gut das funktioniert
immer noch die einzigen das einzige problem was das klo in den ganzen jahren
hatte ist dass der hersteller eine nachricht drum geschickt hat achtung
bitte verwenden sie ihr klo nicht mehr es kann anfangen es kann feuer fangen
und da habe ich mir gedacht ok siehst du mal soweit sind wir schon dass es
brandmeldungen gibt für klos und was gewesen ist
die hatten irgendeinen verschleiß teil was mit der standardmäßigen
reinigungsflüssigkeit nicht zurechtgekommen ist und irgendwie durch
geätzt ist durch gerostet keine ahnung und dann ist die reinigungsflüssigkeit
in die elektronik gelaufen hatten sie angst dass ich das entzünden kann also
jetzt ganz schön gebrannt am arsch
nicht reinigen geht nicht das ist da schon standardmäßig drinne und da kam
dann auch der techniker aber erst leute das ist echt so das ist geil wieder
gewesen
die haben sich mal heißen die heißen die haben sich nicht gemeldet die haben
die haben geschrieben die haben die haben mich angeschrieben haben gesagt hier
klo kann feuer fangen und es würde sich jemand bei mir melden und ich habe
irgendwie zwei monate oder was auch immer gewartet und es hat sich keiner bei
mir gemeldet und ich wollte dass mein klo gefixt wird ja ja stell dir vor du
bist am kacken und dein klo brennt und
und habe ich das gelöscht und dann musste ich die und dann musste ich die
anfangen erstmal flamen auf twitter
da musste ich die flamen auf twitter und dann hat sich abends um 21 uhr
ja und die haben dann abends um 21 uhr noch geantwortet
irgend so eine marketing frau
ja
das hat sich abends noch zur marketing frau gemeldet so nach dem motto ja ja am
anderen tag meldet sich der techniker bei ihnen das ist immer geil wie man
rumflamen muss und jetzt überlegt euch mal ich denke mir immer so wenn ich die
erst flamen muss auf twitter und dass sie dann reagieren die reagieren ja nicht
weil sie es vorher nicht gecheckt haben die reagieren weil die das dann weil
die dann auf twitter gucken und feststellen scheiße das sehen ja ein paar
leute das ist ja schlecht für uns das ist ja marketing stonkstechnisch nicht
gut und deswegen melden die sich dann ich frage mich immer wie verarschen die
eigentlich die leute die keine 20k twitter twitterfollower haben um der
sachen ein bisschen öffentlichkeitswirksam nachdruck zu verleihen
das sieht man ja auch bei das hat man auch bei vodafone wiedergesehen
vodafone übelst am reinscheißen gewesen frame drops im stream ohne ende voll im
arsch die übliche geschichte mit von wegen wir messen mal die leito wir
messen mal die leitung vielleicht kommt ein techniker die werte sehen aber gar
nicht gut aus so wie sie das immer machen und ich habe mich damit erst mal
abspeisen lassen und nachdem es mir dann zu bunt geworden ist habe ich die eine
woche lang erinnert euch vielleicht noch der weite der chat der war dabei und
da habe ich eine woche lang geflamed jeden abend etwa davon etwa davon haben
sie erst ein paar techniker gerührt und geguckt und gemacht da hat mich der
hatte mich damals ich habe ich habe ich nicht noch das vodafone ausreden
dokument
ich hatte vodafone ausreden genau ich habe mir aufgeschrieben mit was sie
sich raus geredet haben da haben wir uns jedes mal weg weg weggekackt im stream
darüber genau dass die erste begründung war vodafone war meine wlan ssid
wird doppelt vergeben das würde dafür sorgen dass ich frame drops im stream
habe ich verwende gar keinen wlan fürs stream muss man dazu sagen also ist
alles per kabel angeschlossen also das das erste was wurde gesagt
dann ist die wlan ssid ist ist doppelt vergeben
so und dann also zwei sachen warum das kompletter komplett komplett sinnlos
des erstens ich gehe überhaupt nicht übers wlan zum stream rein das nächste
ist ich verwende noch nicht mal das wlan aus der vodafone unity media box
sondern meine eigenen access points der techniker am telefon war echt
sichtlich verwirrt als ihm gesagt habe ich verwende euer wlan noch gar nicht
da kam die übliche dann haben sie irgendwas erzählt wie modemwerte haben
schlechte einstrahl was auch immer dann sollte ich noch mal modem neu starten
zwei minuten strom raus hat natürlich nichts gebracht dann haben sie dann
haben sie erzählt es gibt zur zeit probleme mit der connect box ich soll
noch mal das modem neu starten zwei minuten strom raus dann sollte ich noch
mal modem neu starten und die sechste ausrede war großstörungen im raum
hanau frankfurt so und ich habe glaube ich so ziemlich an jedem tag im stream
dann geflämt und ich sag jetzt einfach mal am siebten tag am siebten tag schuf
vodafone dann quasi den ich weiß nicht was es ist so eine art vip kundenbetreuer
oder sowas hat sich dann einer bei mir gemeldet per twitter per pn und hat
gemeint nein nein das darf ja gar nicht sein und er kümmert sich jetzt hat
rum oder sie oder keine ahnung der support mensch kümmert sich da jetzt
rum und wenn ich will kriege ich sogar einen monat refund jetzt meint ihr
ernsthaft die würden random mal einen monat refund anbieten das war einfach
weil ich rumgeflämt habe auf twitter man muss die ganzen dreck säcke
öffentlichkeitswirksam auf twitter flamen dass sie ihre arbeit machen und
seitdem leute seitdem es ist nichts mehr funktioniert alles wunderbar
ich will mich jetzt nicht beschweren ich finde das super dass sie das
hingekriegt haben aber ich frage mich jetzt halt was macht einer der streamen
will vielleicht durch den fünf zuschauer hat 150 leute auf twitter soll
der erst mal soll der erst mal der nick der nächste exklusiv werden dass
wurde von sein internet fix oder was kann nicht sein oder also das ist echt
voll für den arsch ich soll mal kurz runter ich habe die
hälfte im chat nicht gesehen wenn wenn ich jetzt hier grad großen laber stills
gemacht habe
ist das so muss man das mittlerweile sagen
ja komm ich leider leider ey leute ohne mist ich würde gern mein klo irgendwie
in meine heim automatisierung bringen aber das ist so old school das einzige
was das ding hat was nach irgendeinem connector aussieht ist ein serieller
anschluss und man hat keine ahnung was da drüber geht
aber ja mommel dann homeschooling ich finde übrigens auch geil dass wir das
in deutsch homeschooling nenne ich meine es ist mir lieber als teleunterricht ja
das hätte mich auch nicht gewundert wenn man das teleunterricht nennt in
deutschland ja aber ich meine man hätte sich da
sicherlich auch ein cooles ein cooles wort ausdenken können und ich gerade was
und ich was nicht homeschooling ist unterricht übers internet oder irgendwas
unterricht von zu hause was auch immer hätte man da auch mal zu naja und muss
dir echt sagen dass manche lehrer innen auch korrekt mess massive gender plus
ja noch nicht einmal eine videokonferenz vernünftig starten bedienen kann ja
das wundert mich nicht das war damals bei uns auch nicht anders dass die haben
ihre technik auch nicht beherrscht und es ist heute sicherlich noch schlimmer
geworden was ist denn mudel
also das hört sich an wie ein programm von 1995
ja wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ja der desktop ist der beste desktop
gleicher fall ja es ist wieder zeit oh nee auf rett so haben schätzt keinen
bock
mit sicherheit mit sicherheit ja ja die erzählen dir auch sonst was das ist
wahrscheinlich absicht dass du dass die verbindung gedrängt wird und du ruhe
hast und du nicht mit dem gleichen typ rauskommt rauskommt ich ich unterstelle
wo davon und sonst mittlerweile einfach taktik bei sowas auch der telekom
ja nice schön dass du den weg her gefunden hast
ich habe den refund noch nicht mal in anspruch genommen ich habe ich habe ich
habe ihn geantwortet sorgt einfach dafür dass das jetzt gut funktioniert
das reste ist mir egal und hat er gemacht oder jemand das fürs homeoffice braucht
gerade im jahr 2021 leute ohne scheiß es sind so viele leute daheim die von
daheim arbeiten müssen jetzt probleme haben könnt ihr euch noch an die
ersten zwei drei wochen erinnern wo sie sogar youtube gedrosselt haben dafür
dass man tagsüber ordentlich arbeiten konnte wo sie dann auch youtube wo auch
youtube gesagt hat sie machen mit und die folgt wieder gab aber war irgendwie 360
p und sowas erst ein paar wochen bis es dann hinbekommen haben die macht so die
geilen einblendung hiermit ich habe ich habe mir was programmiert so ein kleines
overlay und jetzt habe ich auf dem anderen rechner web interface da kann
ich auf die bilder klicken oder auf die oder auf die sounds
ja und dann ist das da
auf jambe mal eine runde ja ja gibts salz schulisch angeleitetes lernen zu
hause ok das ist das ist aber richtig nice aber am begreifen begriff wieder
g-style 90 dankeschön für den zappen und ich habe ich hoffe ich über sehe nix
mudel ist in pvp gut das wundert mich nicht
ja das gibt es auf github aber das ist nicht die ganz aktuellste version was
hast du vor bf drei abschüttel viel drei ich habe vorher eine runde gespielt es
gibt leider noch ein server und das ist der ist so ein bisschen sketchy
irgendwie da glaube ich nicht dass da alles mit rechten dingen zu geht
müssen vielleicht wieder vanilla spielen wie gesagt ich bin eh nur noch 50
minuten dann haue ich wieder ab ich wollte bloß auch ich wollte bloß mal
den stream an machen das weil ich gestern nicht on war
übrigens meine china leiste geht wieder oder ich habe doch letztens gesagt die
schienen was habe ich nie alles ach so ja gut ist hier noch im wahrenkorb
drin was der der da habe ich letztens gesagt die haben wir doch erst zusammen
geflasht dies wäre jetzt kaputt die geht wieder wackelkontakt im kabel ich
weiß nicht wie die chinesen das hinkriegen bei einer frischen
steckdose leist das wackelkontakt im kabel ist ich habe ich habe hier unten
dran also ich habe hier dran gegriffen da da hier da hat man dran gewackelt geht
wieder an also es ist trotzdem scheiß qualität nicht ganz so schlimm wie ich
rumgeflämt habe letztens nach dem motto zweimal angeschaltet und kaputt aber es
ist ziemlich ergreif wenn es einen wackelkontakt hat bei euch hat die
telekom eine kündigungsbestätigung geschickt ohne dass wir es gekündigt haben ist doch gut
nichts wie weg bei mir hat die telekom eine
auftragsbestätigung geschickt obwohl ich nichts beauftragt habe das ist auch doof
gibt es bald ein minecraft xbox oder pc max server steckwort wie kommst du
darauf dass ich in minecraft selber mache ich hatte mal ein das war ganz lustig
aber mich hatte minecraft nie so großartig gekätscht
ich habe übrigens gesehen ich muss alle meine steckdosen leisten updaten es gibt
ein neues tas mota release
ja 9.2 und ich bin zum größten teil noch auf frag mich nicht auf 7.5 oder so
beste ja
jetzt jetzt jetzt fehlen eigentlich die üblichen verdächtigen im chat die sagen
max warum will man dann eine steckdosenleiste flaschen
aber oder oder es wissen mittlerweile alle das kann natürlich auch sein
für den fall der fälle dass es jemand wissen will warum eine steckdosenleiste flascht zeigt
es nur noch mal ganz schnell damit man zum beispiel so ein schönes web interface bekommt
wo man seine steckdosenleiste übers wlan an und ausschalten kann
und das ganze dann auch in seine heim automatisierung einbinden kann
den habe ich vorhin aktualisiert und das war schon wieder ätzend ging erst nicht
dann muss ich die mini version machen dann voll upgraden voll kacke
und das machen wir heute nicht viel zu teuer viel zu teuer techniker kraut du
meinst diese dreiecke für die wand die sind viel zu teuer da kosten irgendwie
neun stück 160 euro oder immer so viel viel viel zu teuer und du brauchst auch
viel zu viele um so was coole sachen machen machen zu können
es ist auf jeden fall ist es egal ob 7 8 9 10 5 oder was immer sie sind viel zu teuer
du kannst wenn du 3d drucke hast oder oder wenn du handwerklich ein bisschen geschickt
hast und gerne basteln kann man sich sowas recht gut selbst basteln die wären vielleicht nicht
hundertprozentig so industrie create quasi aber auf jeden fall ausreichen
aber das ist dass die dinger sind einfach zu teuer was ich ob es eine touch sensitive
gibt ich finde die dinger ja auch cool und ich habe mir schon überlegt ob ich mir was
ausdrucke und mal selbst so was basteln aber ich wüsste ehrlich gesagt kann also ich finde
sie cool aber wenn ich mich nicht überwinden kann dazu was zu basteln brauche ich wahrscheinlich
absolut gar nicht ansonsten bastel ich ja immer ja genau mit sowas würde sowas würde ich machen
genau das da habe ich auch noch genug leds led leisten für ja das kenne ich aber mein
staubsauger roboter schreit nicht mein staubsauger staubsauger roboter ist aber auch geflasht mit
custom firmware und hat ein webinterface
oh pains champ das hat richtig weh getan
ne tasmo admin funktioniert in der art und weise nicht zumindest nicht so ohne weiteres
weil tasmo admin lässt die geräte sich die firmen vom tasmo admin abrufen und ich müsste
die irgendwie pushen weil die im eigenen netz stehen wo kein tasmo admin drin ist was
futterst du da wie wo was futter ich futter gar nix bin fett genug ich muss nicht immer
was essen lull
ja das ist gut wenn man damit was kleinem startet aber home assistant ist echt das
beste außer man steht auf java dann kann man open hub nehmen aber home assistant ist für
heimautomatisierung echt massive nice und wir müssen das demnächst im stream umbauen
weil ich werde sie in eine vm umziehen ich habe keinen bock irgendwie unsupporten dinger
zu betreiben und wenn es nächstes mal kein bock haben kann ich wieder nicht updaten
ne was ist denn dein ether dahinter dein zugang oder was ne also das das das stimmt also ich
würde sagen das stimmt nicht aber was zugenommen hat ist die dichte an technik und dadurch
dass man quasi also wenn du dir vorstellst du hast vorher keine ahnung 2 3 sachen gehabt
dein nachbar hat auch 2 3 sachen das ist nicht großartig die quere gekommen und jetzt hat
jeder 50 sachen da ist die chance schon mal höher wenn selbst wenn es gleich zufällig
geblieben ist dass öfters was kaputt geht unterstört sich auch mehr
aber das wird mit wifi 6 wahrscheinlich ein bisschen besser ich glaube nicht dass es unzuverlässiger
geworden ist es gibt einfach nur mehr no dread mag ich nicht mein lieblingsessen
es gibt viele sachen die ich gern esse ich meine der klassiker mit spaghetti da kann
es wahrscheinlich jedem kerl ankommen es gibt es gibt glaube ich kaum irgendwie kaum
männer jungen auf der welt wie auch immer die keinen spaghetti mögen aber ansonsten
ich esse ich esse total viel gern von asiatischen sachen was ich meine zeit lang wo ich mich
aber übelst überfressen habe von ist als wir den neuen dönerladen hatten da habe
ich immer pizza sujuk bestellt und ich habe mich da oder es war keine pizza das war diese
diese döner pide sujuk da habe ich mich so übertrieben überfressen mit ich mags nicht
mehr ich habe eine zeit lang gesagt besser als salami pizza mittlerweile esse ich wieder
gern salami pizza weil ich habe mich so überfressen dran ich kann es kann ich mal sehen wieso kein
home bridge weil ich ein produkt brauche was alle möglichen hersteller miteinander
verbindet und am besten der open source ist man kann es aber auch mit home bridge machen
also wenn man wenn man alles machen möchte von ios geräten und wenn man nur dinger verwenden
will die unterstützen ja kann man machen ja schneestell habe ich tatsächlich aufgenommen
könnte ich eigentlich morgen so random einfach mal hochladen was papsfall 2005 ne das das
kenne ich das ist 2005 wo die leute dargestanden haben 2015 wo alle ihr handy hochhalten ich
glaube das kenne ich weil java relevant ist also erstens können viele java bei den leeren
kräften und zweitens ist java immer noch relevant also wenn du mal guckst wie viele
business stonks sachen in java sind da wirst du wahrscheinlich auch weit über die hälfte
kommen ganz viel bankbusiness krempel ist in java und in china stehen die richtig auf
java ich verstehe nicht warum also gut aber die chinesen haben es ja auch so generell
mit menschenrechten nicht so da ist java auch kein problem
ja exquisite ich sehe chat chat wieder richtig massive big brain na kommt kommt drauf an
gibt es auch in milden varianten also wie gesagt zu den wirtschaften informatik master
kann ich überhaupt nichts sagen es kommt darauf an dass du was kannst klar ist ist cool wenn
du studiert hast aber was was das wenn du studiert hast musst du ja ein bisschen was können
sonst hättest du es nicht gepackt also denke ich mal weiß ich nicht aber würde ich mal
vermuten und du müsstest zumindest auch ein bisschen theoretisch ahnung haben und wenn
du irgendwo hin willst wo das von vorteil ist klar ist es nicht verkehrt aber wenn du
wenn du wirklich Richtung programmieren gehen willst du musst halt was können es reicht
nichts wenn du sagst hey ich habe studiert kann aber nichts von dem was ihr braucht aber
dadurch dass du studiert hast hast du sicherlich eine gute base ist also umsonst ist das mit
sicherheit nicht aber planlos darf was ich sagen will ist planlos darf man trotzdem nicht
sein also ein bisschen ahnung von dem was man macht muss man schon haben aber da hast du
sicherlich gute job job chancen dass das das wichtigste ist eigentlich wenn es um die sachen
mit mit job chancen geht ist wo du bist in deutschland also wenn du zum beispiel in frankfurt
oder im rhein-mein-gebiet bist da ist wo du hinguckst ist halt irgendwie wo du können
sagen wo du hinspuckst ist in den rechten zentrum oder in eine software bude oder sonst was
da ist natürlich top wenn du jetzt irgendwie im osten auf dem land bist dann ist das wahrscheinlich
was anderes ja keine ahnung was da draus geworden ist mozilla macht auch in letzter
zeit bei allem kram mit und stellt dann wieder ein das schlimmste an java ist oracle das
stimmt das stimmt oracle ist wirklich massive pains jam die alternative zu java ist kotlin
da haben wir auch so richtige fanboys bei uns auf der arbeit die erzählen bei jedem
in jedem zweiten satz dass ich das jetzt in kotlin neu machen würden was wahrscheinlich
auch echt stimmt nachvollziehbar ist ja du kannst auch skala machen wenn du auf klammern
stehst oder er lang ne wobei warte mal was ist jvm skala oder er lang ne er lang ist
was eigenes ne skala skala ist skala ist java also ist jvm ok ne genau genau skala skala
hat keine klammern mehr was da los skala war war früher da da da also wie keine klammer
was machen die skala programmierer dann dann also skala programm ist dann immer wie fisch
irgendwie fisch emotes aus so ein bisschen weil das jetzt übertrieben so schlimm ist
das nicht groovy ist übrigens auch eine coole sprache für jvm so schlimm ist java gar
nicht ich flames nur immer gern aber ich habe nix gegen java an sich das mag vielleicht
an einigen stellen umständlich sein gut ich habe da jetzt nicht so viel erfahrung durch
dass ich kann das gar nicht so richtig gut einschätzen sie haben lange keine generics
gehabt und was auch immer go by the way immer noch nicht aber ist so ich finde java nicht
schlecht es gibt eigentlich nur eine programmier sprache die ich schlecht finde und das ist
c++ ich finde noch nicht mal cobalt schlecht in dem sinn cobalt stammt halt aus einer zeit
da konnte man es nicht besser das kann ich denen gar nicht vorwerfen aber c++ ist eine
sprache an der wird permanent rum gedockt dort die ist quasi richtig alive hat ein creme
im und alles trotzdem kommt noch kacke bei raus ja kann man machen also wenn du eine sprache
lernen willst die sehr sich sehr an der natürlichen sprechweise orientiert ist ruby auf jeden
fall das beste allerdings das problem wenn man ruby lernt ist man kann damit danach nicht
mehr allzu viel machen weil ruby und rails macht kaum noch einer und auch im adminbereich
ist es eher peisen als als ruby also ruby ist so niche mittlerweile eigentlich dass
ich gar nicht mehr empfehlen würde mit ruby anzufangen früher hätte ich gesagt ruby
ist super ruby zum einstieg aber heute würde ich jedem zum einstieg empfehlen wenn er nicht
genau weiß was er machen will fangen mit java script an und in dem browser weil dann
sieht man wenigstens was passiert was ich für deutlich motivierender halte als bitte geben
sie eine zahl ein programme zu machen
wusste ja vermachen ja es ist auch nicht verkehrt das hatten wir auch bei uns bei uns in der
schule hatten wir hatten wir auch einen fach das an sich it und was wir gemacht haben ist
wörth vorlagen erstellt und sowas aber da siehst du mal was die 015 noobs ok ok bei
mir ist es schon ein bisschen länger her bei mir war das fang ich nicht 2000 oder so ja
aber das ist wahrscheinlich immer noch besser die haben sich damals unter it vorgestellt
wörth vorlagen machen und excel tabellen und wir haben sogar excess verwendet leute
excess ist das schlimmste dinger aller zeiten und der lehrer den wir hatten der konnte ja
auch nichts das einzige was der gemocht hat ist wenn man die seiten lila macht da ist
er dann mit der wörth vor und da hat er sich dann das wörthding ausgedruckt was man gemacht
hat und ist rumgelaufen leila leila leila leila und hat sich voll gefreut das eine eins
gekriegt du musstest das du musstest das nur lila machen also solche spezialisten hatten
wir da am start gehabt klar habe ich ich kann den friseur schon bevor ich youtube gemacht
hab und ich kenne den friseur natürlich immer noch und ich habe auch noch ab und zu kontakt
mit dem friseur es fehlt uns halt aktuell den spiel wir warten ja drauf dass wir wieder
ein spiel gibt was man zusammen richtig bashen kann
welchen tech stack nutzt du beim preis champ der preis champ besteht aus einem open source
crawler in loadjs von github street merchant nennt sich das das ding ich habe ein paar
custom anpassungen gemacht dass ich den ordentlich ordentlich verwenden kann dafür aber nicht
viel kaum 10 zeilen oder so und ein paar custom sachen hinzugefügt die er crawlen soll das
ist so das back end und die front end seite besteht aus einer.net core asp.net core
anwendung und einem vue js front end das ding hat intern plus eine sqlite datenbank weil
ich habe keine parallelen writes oder sonst was also da reicht sqlite ja und eingeliefert
wird das von diesem von dem street merchant direkt an meinen.net core es ist gar nicht
so großartig kompliziert was ich da gemacht habe zum abfragen der ganzen sachen habe
ich craftql dazwischen was ich mittlerweile echt nice finde ich habe mich viel zu lang
mit irgendwelchen komischen rest apis rumgeschlagen wo man dann filter sachen übergeben musste
und sonst was wenn man sachen abfragen will ist was also und filtern will abfragen und
filter will ist craftql wirklich poggers ah yes der chat ist heute wieder extrem 6 hat
fast schon 11 hat wenn ich sowas lese da ist das das gibt es nur gibt es nur in meinem
chat auf twitch warum kopierst du immer das i das i oder die 1 ja das stimmt das habe
ich mir so angewöhnt ja gut es sind ja auch wirtschaft informatiker wenn die wenn die
mehr wert auf wirtschaft legen dann kann das sein bin ich als liegungsatmetik das kommt
darauf an was du machst wieviel jahresgelder du kriegst und welcher region du bist komm
3,5 auf dem konto an oder kriegst du das im vertrag wahrscheinlich kriegst du den vertrag
im konto werden wahrscheinlich irgendwie 1,5 oder sonst was ankommen oder oder 2 2
kommen wahrscheinlich an nicht 1,5 wahrscheinlich kommen 2 oder so an das ist das ist schon
in ordnung je nachdem wo du bist wenn du jetzt in dem wenn du jetzt in einem großen wenn
du jetzt im großen laden bist rein mein gebiet oder so würde ich sagen ist es vielleicht
ein bisschen wenig je nachdem wieviel berufserfahrung du hast da geht schon noch eine ecke mehr
und wie gesagt auch die frage ob 12 oder oder 14 oder sonst was monatsgehälter ansonsten
bei 12 ist es natürlich nicht so viel wenn es 12 sind dann ist es dann ist es ja im prinzip
42k im jahr das ist ein bisschen wenig aber wie gesagt es kommt auf die berufserfahrung
an und vor allem die region wo du bist du hast letztens den scrum test gemacht den was
schick mal den link ich will auch den scrum test machen ich will ich will leute ich muss
euch ich will euch zeigen wie agil ich bin ich ich bin massive agile cloud native agile
git obs solutions chief engineer officer in defops scrum excellence pains jam ach so den
offiziellen scrum test ach so ach so ja ok ich dachte es gibt so einen gibt es irgendwie
so einen test immer machen kann pearl geht gehen wir fort ich habe einmal in meinem leben
eine sache in pearl gemacht und dann nie wieder ja würde ich ist eine gute sache also wenn
man schon ein bisschen weiß was man machen will sie schabt ist finde ich und ich weiß
ich bin übelster sie schabt fanboy also sprich genießt das mit so ein bisschen ja ein bisschen
skeptisch wenn ich darüber auslasse aber ich finde sie schabt ist die beste programmiersprache
die es gibt weil ich sagte es jetzt nicht einfach nur als reiner fanboy weil sie eignet
sich wirklich für nahezu alles du kannst mit sie schabt relativ low level sachen machen
du kannst web anwendung machen du kannst server anwendung machen du kannst desktop sachen
machen du kannst cross platform sachen machen du kannst mobile geschichten zum teil machen
ja kannst du kannst mobile geschichten machen wenn man dieses ganze examiner in zeug mag
kannst web assembly zeug es gibt eigentlich fast nix spiele programmieren in unity es
gibt eigentlich fast nix was du nicht mit sie schabt machen kannst das einzige was mir einfällt
wäre den bootloader programmieren oder sowas ja aber das wollen wahrscheinlich die wenigsten
und das geht mit den meisten anderen programmiersprachen richtig linux desktop anwendung in sie schabt
ist schwierig warum warum es gibt doch elektron.net dann ist es doch auch kein problem mehr ja ich
aber du hast recht die gtk bindings sind kacke und generell ist gtk ziemlich monach s zu
verwenden es gibt ne es gibt ein cooles cute binding für sie schabt was aber auch krankheiten
hat ja ja das stimmt cross platform desktop entwicklung ist nicht so schön es gibt ein
paar projekte es gibt wie heißt das es gibt zwei sie schabt projekte für cross platform
gui uno uno und genau avalonia die zwei das letzte mal wo ich avalonia oi ausprobiert
habe hatte ich nur zwei probleme damit das erste ist es gab kein ordentlichen web view
und du brauchst heute mal vielen anwendungen in web view sei es nur für irgendwelche autentifizierung
sachen oder so klar man kann einen extra browser aufmachen also man kann er umschiffen aber
in web view ist auf jeden fall für eine komplette für den desktop kit ist in web view schon
eigentlich ziemlich essentiell und es hatte keine möglichkeiten dass man dort irgendwie
3d beschleunigter inhalte drin anzeigen kann also ich könnte da zum beispiel keinen ordentlichen
video player machen wo ich die frames selbst rein render oder sowas ich weiß aber nicht
ob das immer noch so ist du hast dir jdk acht bei irgend so warum warum hast du dich einfach
so runtergeladen ich wusste gar nicht dass man um sich die java runtime runterzuladen
zu irgendwelchen dealer seiten gehen muss mittlerweile ist das so ja ich würde aber
ganz im ernst wenn ich wenn ich eine mobile anwendung entwickeln würde dann würde sogar
ich das nicht in c sharp machen als übelster c sharp fanboy ich würde es also gerade also
gerade wenn ich so eine so eine standard also nur 15 also wahrgenommen ich will den preis
camp man genommen ich möchte für den preis camp eine mobile app machen ich würde irgendwas
ionic basierendes nehmen dann nehme ich nämlich einfach mein java script zeug bastel bisschen
native kram drum herum und gut ist bei the way deswegen sacken viele apps mittlerweile
auch so bedienen sich teilweise merkwürdig als im endeffekt nur noch nur noch eine etwas
besser eingepackte webseite ist aber mit native java wird ja gar nicht anfangen
elixir ist er lang echt keine ahnung wusste ich noch nicht das stimmt das stimmt da hast
du recht also mit java finde ich zum anfang auch nicht schön es könnte nur noch schlimmer
sein wenn man mit c plus plus anfängt aber ich finde zum einstieg ehrlich gesagt java
script auch wenn java script echt merkwürdige seiten hat ja finde ich nicht schlecht weil
ich finde es einfach motivierender wenn man sieht was passiert im vergleich zu halt kommando
zeilenprogramme das ist langweilig am anfang du hast dich verschätzt es ist ein zwanzig
vierunddreißig haben die echt noch fort dran sachen wird mich nicht wundern mein alt
ist es ja habe ich habe ich nee habe ich nicht keine ahnung aber die superlux kopfhörer
sind wirklich nice gewesen für den preis ich weiß ich ob die doch was machen aber
die superlux dinger für irgendwie keine ahnung 22 euro oder so waren richtig gut das sind
die die auch in china glaubt für biodynamics oder senheiser die kopfhörer machen superlux
muss man seine registry clean nein musst du nicht deine registry nicht clean wozu also
ganz ernster es gibt auch also gerade im windows umfeld sehe ich bei uns auf der arbeit also
die windows admin leute das sehe ich auch jede menge nups ja ich will nicht ausschließen
dass es in manchen besonderen umständen vielleicht sinnvoll sein kann aber standardmäßig und
regelmäßig muss man das nicht machen wozu leute wisst ihr was ich habe die letzten 15
jahre nicht meine registry gekleint und es ist nie was passiert und das windows läuft
nach wie vor schnell und gut und alles in ordnung ja das genauso wie mein vater früher
der meinte er muss sich tun ab tools tun ab 2007 und so installieren weil sonst ein rechner
so lahm ist der hätte den kram von anfang an runter lassen soll dann wäre immer schnell
gewesen es ist mittlerweile fast schon so ne also niche ist es auf jeden fall seit ruby
on rails nicht mehr angesagt ist und es gibt da noch jede menge sachen drin aber es ist
aktuell nicht so der heiße schitt ruby letztendlich früher oder später wird man total viele
programmier sprachen lernen deswegen deswegen ist es gut sich was zum einstieg zu suchen
ja ja mittlerweile auch schon einiges an programmier sprachen durch krieg ich das überhaupt noch
irgendwie zusammen go javascript c sharp also ganze dotnet geschichte ruby ein bisschen
python javascript bash cobalt bei cobalt es war nur ein gag im stream rust ein bisschen
ich habe ich habe mir sau viel schon angeguckt und ich sage euch eins wenn ihr wenn ihr eine
sprache wirklich gut könnt dann ist es meistens nicht so das große problem eine andere zu
lernen es kann euch dann nur also es kann nur noch in die hose gehen wenn das eine sprache
ist die komplett anders tickt also zum klar zählt besch als programmier sprache zählt
ja mehr oder weniger fast alles zu programmier sprache wo du was automatisch mit machen kannst
es ist einzige was halt echt verwirrend ist ist wenn man beispielsweise wenn ja war gewöhnt
zeit und dann kommt einer mit haskell um die ecke oder so dann wird es vielleicht bissi
eklig warum du programmierst mit dem text in text editor bist du jemand der auch immer
sagt ide ist plaudet richtigen heckermans nur wim na was heißt du wim wie ei wim ist
auch schon richtig plaudet einfach einfach nur wie ei oder eigentlich ist ein editor
interface schon wie ei ist schon editor interface ist schon plaudet eigentlich sollte man nun
per se programmieren das kann ich mir vorstellen als jeder der c++ als einsteiger sprache bekommen
hat hat entweder instant aufgehört musste es machen und hatte überhaupt keinen bock
drauf oder ist zu so einem komischen c++ mensch geworden der jetzt im gremium sitzt und komische
sachen entscheidet ja kann man ja machen ist auch nicht verkehrt da lernt man ein bisschen
cli dabei braucht man eh heute oh gott ich hatte heute wieder leute ich hatte wieder
den profi entwickler am start auf der arbeit könnt ihr könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern
an die geschichte mit dem key value store die ich euch letztens erzählt habe also für
alle für alle die nicht dabei waren ich zeige euch mal was ein key value store ist da gibt
es bestimmt schönes beispiel auf wikipedia genau das ist ein key value store im prinzip
ist es eine tabelle wenn man so will mit zwei spalten nämlich einem key und einem wert dazu
das hat den vorteil das ist im look ab ziemlich schnell und meistens hält man das auch im
ram und und das passt also wenn man im prinzip ist es im prinzip ist es eine art dictionary
ja genau oder eine map oder eine hashmap oder was auch immer wie man es nennt und oder wie
heißt den java script assoziatives array oder was auch immer zumindest übrigens t plus
plus nennt den kram übrigens auch nicht dictionary die nennt es glaube ich hashmap oder so so
zumindest hat er bei uns ein ticket aufgemacht er möchte das ist übrigens auch falsch das
beispiel hier by the way doofes beispiel richtig doofes beispiel das ergibt keinen sinn was
das beispiel das beispiel ist verkehrt wikipedia oder zumindest nicht verkehrt und undeutlich
ist das beispiel ja weiß auch nicht wer das wieder gemacht hat zumindest zumindest ist
es so du hast ein key und einen value das ist halt in den in den zahl oder in den text
oder was auch immer so und der hat ein ticket bei uns aufgemacht ja genau hier hier ne key
und ein value dazu so was hier das das ist das ist schönes beispiel ja ein key ein value
es gibt kein key mit zwei values so genau dass das das triffts im prinzip ganz gut so so
was und dann ein ticket bei uns aufgemacht und hat gesagt hier er möchte er möchte
für diesen key zwei zeilen als ausgabe haben da habe ich ihn gefreut hä was meinst du
denn mit zwei zeilen ich mein man darf nicht vergessen das ist ein entwickler also der
entwickler will ich eigentlich erwissen dass der ungefähr weiß von was er spricht ja
und dann hat er irgendwie gesagt ja er möchte halt dass wenn er den befehl zum abfragen
von diesem key value store schickt dann möchte er zwei zeilen als ausgabe aber du kannst
nur ein value speichern das geht gar nicht das das das das das funktioniert nicht das
einzige was du machen kannst ist habe ich dann zu ihm gesagt wobei ich eigentlich davon
ausgegangen bin dass er das weiß du kannst so einen jason array machen so was hier in
der richtung also du kannst quasi so so einen du kannst quasi den text speichern und wenn
du den text dann passt kommen wieder zwei werte raus so aber key value store ist halt
in der regel so du hast ein key und ein value also du kannst da den objekt oder den array
drin speichern also als text und den text musst du dann wieder passen und dann kriegst du
vielleicht den array raus so und dann hat er erst gemeint irgendwie ja jetzt nochmal
langsam ich erkläre das nochmal also er hat es so getan als hätte ich nicht verstanden
ok zumindest sind wir dann drauf gekommen alles gut alles klar ich mache ich mache ihm
den array und dann sind wir sogar noch drauf gekommen ich muss das gar nicht machen weil
das irgendwo anders herkommt und heute gab es ein neues ticket und heute gab es neues
ticket er hat rausbekommen wir müssen das doch machen und er will er will immer noch
zwei werte für ein key du kannst keine da nein das funktioniert nicht wie soll das
wie soll das bei einem key value store funktionieren das ding heißt nicht umsonst key value store
du chat du kannst nur ein value dazu speichern das heißt nicht key values store das heißt
key value store was du machen kannst ist ja bei reddis geht das reddis macht trick 17
du kannst den du kannst beispielsweise du kannst tricken du kannst sowas nehmen wie
key 1 2 3 und das dann als array implementieren was nur key heißt das das kannst du machen
ja oder aber du nimmst als value ein serialisiertes objekt also serialisiertes objekt als string
und den speicherst du als value das kannst du machen du hast aber keine möglichkeit
in dieser datenbank struktur zwei values zu speichern dafür sowas kannst du machen du
kannst dann ein objekt draus machen du kannst da quasi diesen string draus machen und den
speicherst du als value was in der datenbank drinne steht ist aber key user 1 value dieser
text das ist dann in der datenbank nicht sonst was es mag sicherlich implementierung geben
die das so ein bisschen fördern und sonst was aber vom grundlegenden gedanke gibt es
ein key und ein value dazu so und zumindest zumindest bei dem key value store den wir haben
ist es relativ klar du kannst da eh nur text drinne speichern ja und da wollen wir da
zwei keys haben da hat sich davon dann abringen lassen nicht zwei keys zwei values und ich
habe ihm das dann als json array reingespeichert also quasi so ein bisschen so ein bisschen
sowas wie hier so habe ich ihm das reingespeichert dann hat er meint nein die ausgabe ist falsch
er will zwei zeilen und ich hätte es fast schon aufgegeben ich wusste echt nicht
wie ich das dem jetzt verklickern soll ich meine ernsthaft entwickler warum weiß ein
entwickler so war es nicht ich habe fast schon ausgegeben bis dann einer von unseren java
pros angekommen ist und hat gemeint hat ihm das noch mal das gleiche geschrieben das gibt
nur ein value und er soll sich halt ein passendes trennzeichen überlegen und dann hat es endlich
eingesehen und meinte ja können wir nicht den zweiten key machen war schon all da gott sei
dank ja das können wir machen das kein problem wir machen einfach einen zweiten key hätten wir
schon gleich machen können ja hätte sich darauf bestanden dass du zwei zeilen haben willst
war ganz davon abgesehen wenn man wenn man noch entwickler ist dann kann man doch einfach sich
das selbst raus passen wenn man nicht ich schon eine jason library hat die das macht was das problem
verstehen die leute manchmal echt nett ja das hatten wir schon ja oder nein heute würde ich
sagen er brachte der tatsache dass noch 14 minuten tendier ich zu nein was für ein ding
würdest du das einstiegs galt für den staatlich geprüften techniker für computer ich würde eher
sagen du müsst noch eine ausbildung machen weil den kram keiner haben will so plötzlich anhört
das sind diese ganzen techniker berufe die man an der schule macht das juckt kein es sei denn du
bist echt richtig gut und überzeugt die leute halt damit dass du halt richtig gut was kannst
und dann kannst du das verlangen was jeder andere dafür auch verlangen kann aber ganz
ehrlich diese ausbildung oder diese schulischen werdegänge sind meiner mann noch totaler schrott
oder hast du jemals schon schon eine stellenanzeige gesehen wo drin steht wir suchen ein staatlich
geprüften techniker von computersystem und netzwerk technik oder umgedreht hast du schon
mal eine stellenanzeige gesehen wo drin steht wir suchen ein mit studium abschluss oder vergleichbare
ausbildung oder techniker ausbildung kingwall das hat nichts damit zu tun ob du handwerker
bist oder nicht das ist ein schulische eine schulische ausbildung die heißt so das hat
mit handwerker sei nichts zu tun also ich halte davon nicht viel ausbildung machen ist
sinnvoller das stimmt das da muss ich auch was zu erzählen wir hatten mal ein unternehmens
wir also wir haben öfters mal so unternehmensberatungen da weil wir sind der big strongs bank ja und
da hatten wir auch welche da die waren super agil die waren so was von agil die wollten
dann von uns dass wir ein marketplace veranstalten ich wusste bis dahin gar nicht mal dass es
gibt ich habe gedacht das ist ein gebäude in anno oder so ich habe keine ich wusste
bis dahin gar nicht was ein marketplace überhaupt sein soll und da haben wir uns erzählt das
ist eine agile eine agile methode ich habe es ehrlich gesagt habe ich schon wieder vergessen
was uns genau erzählt haben wie es denn jetzt ist zumindest ging es darum zumindest ging
es darum dass man sich dann mit fünf sechs gruppen und jeder an der tafel ist kein wiss
tafel und pinnwand hinstellt und sein projekt noch mal der breiten öffentlichkeit präsentiert
aber nicht einfach stinknormale präsentation macht sondern wo dann die leute so im kreis
gehen und wo dann wo dann jeder aus dem team einmal drankommt zum erklären und jeder auch
jeder zu einer anderen station geht und so was das ist so ein typischer ich muss dazu
ich bin nicht gegen alles ja ich finde ich finde einiges auch echt sinnvoll aber da
muss ich sagen das ist echt so ein so ein an den haren herbeigezogene agile schrott
gewesen weil ganz im ernst du hast nun mal in einem team oftmals leute die können das
besser mit präsentieren und welche die können das schlechter und es ist im endeffekt dann
darauf rausgelaufen dass die gleichen leute immer präsentiert haben und nicht rumgelaufen
sind also so wie es eigentlich zu erwarten war ja ja das war echt krepp nicht wie ja
genau es ist ab dürfte eines der meisten verbreiteten programmier sprachen für games
mittlerweile dank unity sein überhaupt gut für klassischerweise ist es da eac plus plus
was man ja auch an real sieht aber gratis unity ist es halt echt saumäßig verbreitet
mittlerweile wobei man sagen muss ich glaube unity ist ja so ein eigener mischmasch ne unity
ist ja nicht weder dotnet korn doch noch dotnet framework unity ist ja unity
bin ich bin ich wieder zurück gejumpt im chat oder was ist hier los kommen wir gar
nicht hinterher es kommt ganz drauf an was du kannst wo du landest das kann man so pauschal
immer nicht sagen vielleicht sollte ich mir das noch mal angucken ich schreibe mir das
mal kurz auf streamidee exzellent das kann ich ein bisschen rausschmeißen strado strado
funktioniert nicht die haben die haben bindung von einem monat und das will ich nicht will
kein server zum testen den monat kaufen ne vlc bindings bringen die da nix wenn du irgendwie
open glo direct x in den fenster rennen willst oder als surface verwenden willst dann brauchste
irgendwas was das ui framework kann was dann selbst wiederum native verknüpfung zu der
jeweiligen platform hat was je es kommt drauf an also sie schab hat standardmäßig sowas
nicht es kommt auf das jeweilige ui framework an also windforms hat halt das olle ding wpf
hat ein bisschen was neueres uwp hat was ganz neues und die haben es jetzt aber so gemacht
dass du glaube ich den den den neuen edge chrome kannst du jetzt glaubt auch in wpf
und windforms irgendwie verwenden oder so was auch immer microsoft ertreibt microsoft
hat die chance gehabt mit mit win ui ein ordentliches gutes windows ui framework zu machen haben
aber wieder die hälfte verkackt dabei das so typische microsoft geschichte dazu kann
ich nichts sagen kenne ich mich null aus mit was oracle so treibt
ne will ich noch will ich noch ausprobieren ich habe mal flatter installiert und die beispiel
app aufgemacht hallo welt und bisschen rumgeklickt das war es
ne mache ich nicht weil ich mich mit direkt nicht gut auskenne und ich wenn meistens schon
eine fertige anwendung habe und ich das nur noch mehr oder weniger konvertieren will
und vielleicht native notifications dabei machen will also was web anwendung angeht
ist der preis jam total nur nach 15 ja das habe ich ja schon beantwortet oder bin ich
jetzt wieder ah the fuck pick nicht mehr durch ja aber seitdem es erst in gewalt bei java
script gibt ist es doch gar nicht so ganz okay wieder mittlerweile nutzt du mehr windows
oder linux also nachdem ich ja hier bei mir auf dem desktop linux in der vm laufen habe
was ja heißt ich kann die vm gar nicht verwenden ohne dass windows läuft verwende ich mehr
windows bestimmt jaja klar c++ dürfte eines der ersten
sachen sein die drack jetzt für web assembly hatten ach wie assembly da brauche den separo
dazu du hast dir doch das nas selber gebaut würdest du jemand der nicht basse oder programmier
begabt ist empfehlen nee da wünscht ihr empfehlen kauft ihr ein fertiges die seinolege dinger
haben richtig riesen ökosystem und die die seinolege apps sind auch ganz gut und wenn
du gar keine ahnung hast mal kauft ihr was fertiges so ein riesen preislicher unterschied
ist es auch nicht ich halte nichts von sich halt generell nichts von c++ aber c++ anfangen
noch noch schlimmer da lernst du so komische sachen wie dass die default string klasse
kacke ist und ich will jetzt eigentlich ich will jetzt nicht mit c++ anfangen ich fange
jetzt nicht mit c++ an was haben die sich eigentlich bei der c++ lambda sonntag egal
nein fangen wir jetzt nicht mit an das kommt ungefähr hin ja ich würde sogar sagen wenn
programmier sprachen mit zählen noch ein paar mehr ja christel sagt weil christel selbst
sagt sie sind nicht rubikompatibel und ich glaube christel läuft nicht mehr unter windows
das check ich nicht
du musst garantiert keine ports öffnen wenn beide geräte im gleichen netzwerk sind also
ich habe den ich habe den den stream link noch nie verwendet ich habe meinen eigenen
stream link auf dem zweiten monitor laufen ich brauche das nicht aber das muss halt was
anderem liegen also ports weiterleiten bringt ja nichts wenn die dinger wenn die dinger
im gleichen netz sind macht ein router einfach gar nichts damit
ja finde ich schon dass das die diskussion finde ich auch immer geil eigentlich ist das
heutzutage kann man das gar nicht mehr gar nicht mehr sagen und außerdem ist die unterscheidung
schon immer blödsinnig gewesen weil es geht nicht darum ob programmier sprache oder skript
sprache sondern eigentlich ist programmier sprache der überbegriff für alles und da
drinne kann man vielleicht noch zwischen interpretiert und kompiliert unterscheiden wobei das heute
auch fließend ist je nach sprache ja also erstmal ist alles eine programmier sprache
und da kann man es dann drinnen unterteilen das aber eine wilde mischung was ist er klingt
wie viele sprache aus dem rpg maker ey ohne misst wenn ein azubi sagt er programmiert
in html bin ich wahrscheinlich der einzige der ihn nicht auslacht ansonsten ist das ja
so ein gefundenes fressen für also null wusstest du nicht html ist keine programmier sprache
wir wissen es besser ich sagte einfach nichts zu es ist zwar streng genommen keine programmier
sprache aber mittlerweile ist html und was du machen kannst komplex genug dass ich das
einfach gelten lasse ja wird makro ist eine programmier sprache ja ist so ist ist so zwar
vielleicht keine schöne aber im prinzip schon ja auch vba ist eine programmier sprache
wäre auch eine hässliche ja aber nur aus dem 3d drucker glaube ich habe den chat gleich
aufgeholt da kann ich ins bett gehen easy perfekt so machen wir immer streams einfach
eine stunde chat vorlesen und dann gehe ich auf perfekt schnell spammen dass der chat
nicht aufhört ja das könnte jetzt natürlich auch mal ach du scheiße ernsthaft ok es gibt
es gibt leute also es gibt ja im prinzip für jedes ding auf der welt einen der es geil
findet und das gibt es halt auch für c++ c ist ok c ist ein gutes c ist nice c++ ist
halt kacke ich weiß gar nicht mehr ach so du meinst aus dem video ja excellent fuck
ich bin jetzt erst das habe ich doch vor einer halben stunde erst schon erzählt kann auch
sein kann auch sein
ok jetzt mal ein bisschen schneller quatsch dem geht's gut mir fällt an ich musste mir
fällt ein ich muss ihn immer noch zurück rufen hat mich letzten dienstag oder so angerufen
ich habe es zu spät gesehen und ich habe noch nicht zurückgerufen so ist das so bin
ich so bin ich halt l chat so ist das halt dem geht's gut also alle die gerüchte erzählen
haben schlicht ergreifend keine ahnung ja ist er anscheinend das sieht echt so aus
nein kann ich nicht ich hätte euch das nicht erzählen soll wobei eigentlich ist ja lustig
ja was was nur echt merkwürdig wäre wenn der typ zufällig mal im chat vorbei guckt
und auf einmal alle schreiben übrigens leute dieses video hier was ich letztes gemacht
habe wenn der chef dich verarscht mein chef hat das video geguckt hat mich gestern oder
glaube gestern angeschrieben aber es geht ja nicht um ihn es ging um den alten arbeitgeber
wo ich war da war er auch also da hat er hat im prinzip plus gesagt so ja er hat sich auch
wieder dran erinnert wie kacke das da gewesen ist ich habe übrigens ein video auf privat
gestellt ich habe vor einer weile mal ein video gemacht wo ich naja sachen gehackt habe
stimmt nicht wo ich mir origin bisschen genauer angeguckt habe aber sowas fällt ja heute
mittlerweile schon fast unter hacken auf youtube und ich habe echt keinen bock mich mit damit
youtube rum zu streiten ob das jetzt hacking content ist oder nicht man hat es bei semper
video gesehen keine ahnung kein schimmer ob ich da irgendwo beigetreten bin im battle
log mache ich ist schon auf dem weg das ist unter das ist unterschiedlich dass das kann
ich jetzt so auf die schnelle geheimnis das ist unterschiedlich also das kommt ein bisschen
drauf an wer wer wer das macht und und aus welchem bereich das kommt also bei uns läuft
es im prinzip zum größten teil über geht kommets und confluence wobei es halt so ist
dass man die leute manchmal ein bisschen dazu drängen muss das ordentlich zu machen aber
im prinzip sind es gibt gibt kommets und confluence für langlebigere sachen
aber die grundidee finde ich auch super und wenn es ordentlich gemacht ist dann ist es
auch eine tolle geschichte ich war aber erst einmal in einem was ich mal das projekt nennen
kann in einem ja doch im prinzip in dem projekt zwar ein eigenes team aus leuten die sonst
nichts miteinander zu tun hatten wo wo scrum und agil gut funktioniert hat und meiner mein
auch richtig gemacht wurde und eine ganz entscheidende sache was was sonst glaube ich die leute nicht
gebacken kriegen ist und was was da echt gut gemacht war es gab zwar daily scrums und gedöns
und sonst was also daily zusammenstehen und sowas und sich kurz austauschen aber es wurde
von anfang an klargestellt dass es nicht schlimm ist wenn man auf so einem daily scrum nichts
neues zu sagen hat weil ansonsten dauert es ewig und jeder muss sich da profilieren
weil die anderen sonst denken er macht nix also das finde ich ist eine ganz wichtige
geschichte wenn man so solche daily dinger macht die eigentlich nur zehn minuten dauern
sollen dann muss das auch ok sein wenn man sagt also ich habe für die runde heute nichts
interessantes so und das problem ist dass das meistens so nicht gehandhabt wird sondern
trotzdem dann eben noch einer dabei steht der quasi kritisch guckt wenn einer nix sagt
was dann wieder dazu führt dass die leute sich genötigt fühlen sich dinger auszudenken
und es auszuschmücken und zu beschönigen und danach dem motto wer nix sagt er hat
noch nix gemacht und dann läuft das wieder komplett aus dem rude also das muss ordentlich
gehandhabt sein dann kann das richtig gut funktionieren das macht auch spaß also das
ist das ist richtig nice wenn man nicht permanent an irgendwelche stonks raum bedingungen denken
muss oder einfach was machen kann also ich finde es nicht ich finde es nicht schlecht
aber es muss gut gemacht sein was es leider meistens nicht ist wie gesagt ich war erst
in einem projekt dabei wo das wirklich richtig gut geklappt hat und es war witzigerweise
auch wirklich was wo sie sich einen beratungs scrum master typ geholt haben da muss man
echt sagen der konnte das auch wahrscheinlich hat er so viel verdient wird das gesamte team
in drei jahren oder so aber er konnte das auf jeden fall also ich habe gar nichts dagegen
wenn einer viel verdient er sollte zumindest er sollte zumindest das können wofür er da
ist
keine ahnung
das stimmt besser gesagt ihr unterhaltet euch mit dem zukunftsmax aus ähm eurer sicht
wie switcht du von vm rüber auf den anderen desktop äh ich drücke control windows taste
und feile ja und je nachdem wie du es gemacht hast musst du in der vm auch erstmal control
alt drücken aber control alt und control windows liegt direkt nebeneinander so dass
es in einem in einem rutsch geht man kann es aber auch anders machen man kann ein makro
beispielsweise in seiner maus software machen oder irgendwo anders die das dann automatisch
würde ich drücken
es geht es geht nicht um irgendwie ein gestatt staatlich geprüft es geht um den ausbildungsberuf
es gibt es gibt diese sache mit staatlich geprüfter äh informationstechnik oh ne wie
geht das informationstechnik sowas da das meine ich und das sagt das ist massive sack
das da machst du besser eine ausbildung falls du was anderes gemeint hast dann nehme ich
das alles zurück und äh behaupte das gegenteil und sage ich hab keine ahnung von aber ich
dachte du meinst sowas in dieser richtung hier so ne rein zwei jahre reine schulische
ausbildung und das ist echt mega sack
also falls du was anderes meinst dann bist du noch wer auch immer das gefragt hat ich
weiß ich aber noch da ist dann hab ich das nicht so gemeint dann hast du aber keine zwei
jahre schulische ausbildung gemacht
max risk dankeschön primes ab drei monate ne gibts nicht
chillfreak das können wir im nächsten stream machen muss ich erstmal hier beikommen das
ich dann ausmachen kann ja also singleplayer rpg spielen sie immer noch gerne wenn sowas
gutes gibt äh was wo hab ich mich gepreist gemmt
stimmt doch stimmt doch da steht nicht 5300 5600 und das x ist normal die haben alle x
hinten dran das stimmt deswegen muss ich mich auch so viel mit c++ umschlagen äh weil
es peering von einem provider sagt ist ist derjenige noch da dem ich das mit dem techniker
erzählt hab also wie gesagt das stimmt nicht was ich gesagt hab wenn das was anderes ist
als das was ich gerade aufgemacht hab
tau b a wenn du gar nichts meinst du kannst du kannst in dotnet in c-sharp kannst du wunderbar
excel geschichten machen gibt's richtig coole libraries für aber ansonsten so ganz ohne
programmierkenntnisse weiß ich da nix
ja kann man kann man aber das ist ja leider c++ das heißt die arduino standarddinger
sind
nice aber sobald man es drüber raus geht ist halt eklig
ja sehe ich auch so
das seid ihr nicht agil genug im osten für
äh agile leute brauchen scrum master
äh das war irgendwas wo ich äh programmiert hab dass du auf den esp 32 über https eine
neue firme hochladen kannst
war aber technisch nicht so wahnsinnig ausgereift hab das mittlerweile ein bisschen überarbeitet
ja das ist das das ist sicherlich fürs fürs auskennen nicht verkehrt ist halt die frage
ob dir das jetzt beruflich großartig was gebracht hat
ich mein wenn du das sagst ok ich will easy fachabi machen und danach studieren also ist
das bestimmt ein weg aber als ersatz für die ausbildung nicht also es sucht niemand
danach und du hast damit auch keine sonderlich großen pluspunkte wenn er wenn jemand einen
sucht und du sagst du hast was gelernt
oh leute ich hab's geschafft easy ich bin durch
na gut nachdem ich nicht studiert hab kann ich dir aus erster hand nichts sagen aber
ich kenn genug leute die studiert haben ähm wenn man an theoretischen grundlagen interessiert
ist beziehungsweise in diese richtung irgendwie gehen will musst du studieren in der ausbildung
lernst du kaum nicht nichts mathematisches an grundlagen keine wirkliche informatik dazu
musst du studieren ja
also wenn du einen binary tree ein binary tree inverten willst dann musst du informatik
studieren gut das kriegt man auch so hin aber wenn man sowas machen will und die hintergründe
lernen will und sich bisschen für algorithmen und sowas interessiert dann ist das studieren
auf jeden fall die bessere sache weil in der ausbildung lernt man eigentlich nix theoretisches
also nix wirklich höheres theoretisches ja kannst du knicken
ich kenn mich da auch nur bei einigen dingen aus weil mich das selbst interessiert und
ich da mit selbst ein paar sachen angeguckt habe
das stimmt berufsschule ist kacke
ja genau
ne also
ein binary tree ist ein tree der immer nur zwei knoten hat oder nur nur zwei
soll man sagen child nodes
also jeder knoten hat nur zwei und maximal zwei unterknoten
hat der alles geskept nö ich hab alles gelesen
ja berufsschule berufsschule ist wirklich sack also berufsschule ist halt echt so ein
ding ich bin in der schule immer übelst faul ja und ich hatte zumindest früher in der
schule auch keine guten noten weil ich so ultra faul gewesen bin ich hab halt immer
genau das gemacht dass ich durchgekommen bin nicht mehr und nicht weniger
und ich hatte in der berufsschule nur einsen und ich hab auch nichts gemacht gar nichts
ich hab nichts gelernt ich hab nicht mich vorbereitet nichts gemacht wirklich gar nichts
also das sagt alles über die berufsschule berufsschule kannst du auf der halben arschbacke
machen kriegst trotzdem einsen
ja genau berufsschule ist mega chillig aber lernen tust du nix und schwierig ist es auch
nicht
das kann kein binary tree sein was meinst du warum das binary heißt weil es zwei stück
hat wenn du nen binary baum hast mit wo nen knoten mehr als zwei unterknoten hat dann ist
es kein binary tree mehr das sagt ja schon der name das ist ein trinary tree ist es
dann tertiary tree oder was auch immer ja bvl war das nervigste in der berufsschule
11 hat die meisten leute sind nicht high IQ unterwegs
also wenn ich muss nur mal im zug um dich gucken was meinst du wieviel davon high IQ
unterwegs sind die einzigen die high IQ unterwegs sind auf twitch ist ja auch nur der chat hier
der chat hier ist exquisite big brain das kommt allerdings auch durch die ganzen subs
weil wir wissen ja eins abgibt IQ plus plus
das gute ist an dieser ganzen berufsschule iak geschichte es interessiert faktisch gesehen
absolut keine sau mehr ähm was man da für eine note hatte
jetzt wirds aber big brain hier chat ja time to sleep ja ist echt so so siehts aus ok
leute also wir sehen uns ich bin ja heute nur mal ungekommen weil ich gestern war ich vor
gestern on glaub nicht oder den geh ich jetzt mal auf gucken ob wir den friseur oder irgendjemand
hosten können der frazier wo ist er nicht on was neun tage was ist mit dem friseur los
warum ist neun tage ich dachte er muss bdo kreiten
verstehe ich nicht bitte nicht corona oder irgendwas haben
neun tage ist es wenn der bdo kreit ansteht ist aber ganz schön
tja da muss ich ihn mal fragen was da los ist
können kronk hosten oder alt alpha vier games was spielt er denn
ist das echtes n64 das sieht so gut aus für n64 game
ja das ist n64 game
wir hosten jetzt alpha 4 games
also
also leute machts gut ich geh jetzt auf ich bin jetzt auch nicht drüben im chat wir sehen
uns bis denn
see you